all right it
is september 2nd so it's time for
another
monthly update video in which i'm going
to talk about
what went on in the month of august very
busy month here
and what we've got coming up in the
month of september so i always like to
begin by
talking about three big things big thing
number one of course is that we're going
back to school i
am teaching six classes i'll tell you a
little bit more about that
uh in just a bit and it is
a lot of work so that's one thing going
on but it's also going to result in a
lot of content being produced
big thing number two for the worlds of
speculative fiction series which we're
continuing
in a completely virtual format we're
going to be
looking at ursula k le guins wizard of
earth see
trilogy the first three books of the
earth c
stuff we're going to look at the other
three books and the stories that come
with it
next month as well so we're going to do
a double header
and the other big thing that i want to
put on everybody's radar so it's not
happening this month
but well actually one what i think one
stoic on x is already lined up for this
month
we have stoicon and stoic week
coming up in october so if you read
stoicism today of which i'm the editor
you are going to see a lot of content
coming out
about that as we prepare and gear up
we're also going to be having a stoicon
x
here based in the midwest although it's
going to be a virtual event so
everybody will be able to attend but
i'll talk more about that later on down
the line
august was a pretty busy month we're
pretty lucky that it had 31 days
i turned 50 which was kind of a cool
thing
and we actually held an online birthday
bash
i also put together an amazon list that
people
selected things from to send me birthday
presents including
quite a few cool band t-shirts and a
number of books that i'm very happy to
have
that i can definitely use for my studies
including the big old uh wizard of
well actually not just wizard diversity
the whole earth sea chronicles
in one omnibus volume so that was one
big thing that happened for us
and then also on a personal note my
oldest daughter
came up here moved to about five miles
north of here
she's attending university of
wisconsin-milwaukee so
i've already gotten to do one massed-up
visit with her
and so that that's very nice to have her
here i hadn't seen her since
since christmas time because of covid so
that's really cool she's going to be
studying musical theater
at the peck school of arts which is
really just excellent
it's great to have her here in the same
town seeing her
you know making her transition into
adulthood i asked her you know do you
want me to call you every
every day like we used to she's about
once a week is probably good
so so that's kind of a good sign
and there's a lot of other things that
went on we had our usual online events
of course all of our events are now
online rather than face to face so we
did the worlds of speculative fiction
uh we focused on walter miller and his
leibowitz novels
did my normal ama my wisdom for life
sessions that we video recorded as well
as audio recorded
did my political theory and practice
hang out
and of course offered the classic metal
class along with scott taruli
videos for all of those can be found if
you click uh show
show more or see more in your your
youtube
you know interface whatever it happens
to be you'll see the links to those
below
of course the really big thing for
august is that i've been spending a lot
of time
doing production of resources for my
courses
i'm teaching six courses this semester
which is
a pretty significant load six different
preps
so one of them is for milwaukee area
technical college
and it's in the second chance pell
program which is for inmates
it's a really good program that required
me to go into matc and upload a lot of
video content for the
prison students who as of yet are not
yet in the classes unfortunately
there's usually some some things that
get messed up when you're dealing with
the doc i also got sort of
roped into teaching another class for
matc i wasn't planning on doing that but
they only have a few people qualified to
teach ethics
and they had classes that they needed to
be
filled so i i'm teaching ethics for them
again
and that class started this week for
milwaukee
institute of art and design another
place that i i teach
i started two classes this week one is
existentialist philosophy and literature
and i'm building out a lot of you know
cool content for that you may have seen
some of the kierkegaard uh present age
videos i also been recording some videos
on dostoyevsky and then
chest off is coming up going on and then
i'm teaching a world religions class as
well that's that's a lot of fun
but putting that into an online format
that's that's challenging
i'm also teaching two classes for
carthage college
originally i was intended to teach one
business ethics which is kind of
a staple for me but they also had
another professor who dropped out
and they had a biomedical ethics class
that needed
somebody to design it and teach it so
it's a little bit out of my normal
wheel well but i've been teaching
professional ethics for a long time and
and you know some of that includes
things in that field
so i said okay i'll i'll do that so i'm
teaching six classes
and all of them are online all of them
have some
meeting components with the students
whether it's through chat
or through video conferencing or things
like that
i've also been doing a lot of client
work picked up a few new
uh tutorial and philosophical counseling
clients
i'm very lucky and that people are
always coming my way because i do
zero marketing and uh in fact
i get people on linkedin all the time
telling me i can do marketing for you
and i'm like well i don't actually
need it at this point a lot of work this
last month for stoicism today
as we gear up for the fall where we have
stoic week
stoicon stoicon x's
all those things you know i'm because
i'm the editor of stoicism today i
have to publicize those fortunately
we've got more people working
on it this year and so that's kind of
cool and i will be
one of the standby speakers for
the main stoichon this year
they they filled up the roster and then
donald robertson was like
just in case somebody like can't make it
or drops out
would you be on deck for that and so
for once i'm not going to be having to
speak
unless something goes wrong in which
case i'll be doing a talk
i and that's pretty much it as far as oh
milwaukee sofia we also had our session
for
september yesterday we also met for
august so we're getting back on track
for that
video work you may have seen in other
sadler stories videos that i did i'm
going to do more of those
this this coming month half hour hegel
i got two videos out this month so i'm
quite happy about that
and core concept videos i i
shot some on hume some on kierkegaard
that i
released of course the events videos the
you know classic metal class the
political theory
and practice discussion the ask me
anything
session all of those you can find linked
to below and the wisdom for life
sessions that we recorded
we also video record them so you can
watch those
i did a good bit of podcast work this
last month in part gearing up because i
use these as resources for my classes so
recently you've seen the releases of the
peter singer
podcast episodes made from the videos of
course
some on heraclitus some on plato's
republic before and prior to that
epicurus on the principal doctrines and
letter to
uh
cs i always get his name a little bit
mixed up and stumble over it
so that's the month of august a lot
going on there
what's coming up this month of september
so september is going to be a crazy
crazy busy month we not only have the
usual events coming up and i've got my
client work with philosophical
counseling consulting
tutorials all that six classes
ongoing all of them online all of them
content that i
develop all of them involving some sort
of interaction
with students the mere fact that they're
online doesn't mean that there isn't a
lot to
to do on my part these are not
correspondence courses
these are well-built you know full
robust
online courses for three different
colleges in
six different classes so that said
let's talk about events on uh this this
saturday coming up on the 5th at 12
p.m all the times by the way central
time
since i live here in milwaukee will have
my
ask me anything session my ama you can
jump in on that make sure you get your
questions in early
because i can't get to all of them so
and make sure that you only ask your
question once it doesn't do any good to
repeat it i'm not going to take more
notice of it the second time or third
time around
on the ninth we'll at 5 pm we have the
public
hegel q a and discussion session that's
that's open to anybody who wants to talk
about
hegel we've been getting a lot of
interesting people coming in
and engaging in discussions
on the 12th at 12 p.m
we'll have the next classic metal class
this will be number five
i've decided the subject matter this
time around is going to be
mid 70s british metal and what was going
on with it what kind of transformations
were taking place
how is heavy metal coalescing into
something identifiable
as a musical movement particularly in
britain including of course scotland and
and
and whales and we can also talk a little
bit about some some you know uh
overflows from from other places as well
so that is going to be a important
session scott truly will hopefully again
be
be able to join me as my special guest
contributing a lot of his musical
knowledge
on the 19th we've got a double header
event
at 12 p.m we'll be doing the video
premiere
for the worlds of speculative fiction
this time on ursula k le guin's earth
sea trilogy of
novels and then following that
at 1 30 p.m we will have an
even more interactive event because of
course you can
engage in live chat during the video
premiere
but after that we'll have a video
conferencing session
using zoom and we'll talk more about
those
those works we're only going to be
focusing on the first three novels
uh the other earth sea stuff we're going
to do next month so it's going to be
split
over two months but that doesn't mean
you can't talk about
other books by leguin or anything like
that bring bring your
you know your interests to the session
on the 20th the next day at 12 p.m we'll
have our
political theory and practice discussion
i'm not sure what topic
we're going to pick yet and waiting to
see what happens with a lot of things
going on
especially as we get closer to the
election but guaranteed
we will have a topic so on the 24th
at 6 pm we will have our
mke that's milwaukee's stoic fellowship
that is virtual
and so you don't have to live in
milwaukee or even wisconsin to join in
with us you do want to make sure that
you're
reading the the book that we're
discussing which is on tonia mccarro's
more than happiness really great book
about buddhism
and stoicism and some other topics that
is that at 6 p.m central
time uh also meeting by zoom so feel
free to join us if you'd like to
and then if i get to it on the 26th at
12 p.m
we will hopefully have another video
premiere
of a self-directed study video
i've been trying to get one done on
augustine for
quite a while and you know there's a lot
to say about augustine i might actually
switch it up and do it on somebody else
who's a little bit easier to talk about
we'll see what happens
there's a lot going on this month we may
get to it we may not get to it
let's talk about videos coming up this
month i didn't get my
book review videos done this month one
of those things that fell
by the wayside and hoping to get them
done this month so you should see some
of those coming out i'll be telling some
more sadler's stories
we have all of the event videos from
online events coming up and video
premieres
um i'm also going to be shooting a lot
of core concept videos i'm going to
continue on with kierkegaard
and the present age releasing those i'm
now shooting videos on
dostoyevsky's the brothers karamazov and
then after that
i'm shooting core concept videos on lev
shestops all things are possible
chest off is a rather lesser known
author but
definitely worth reading if you're into
existentialism
so we'll see what i do after that
really i got to get stuff done for my
existentialism class
so probably if i release anything else
this month
it'll be some more camus and some
gabriel marcel content
that will be you know finishing up the
the text that i never
truly got to the end of
half our hegel videos i'm going to try
to shoot for getting six done this month
we'll see i haven't done that for quite
a while but
at least i'm getting some of those done
and
i think that's pretty much it as far as
video work it's already a lot
podcast i am again producing things for
my students
so what do my students need they need
some more plato they need some more
aristotle they need some
jon stewart mill they need some jeremy
bentham
they need some augustine so i'm going to
be churning those
out as best as i can and
getting those done i should also mention
too when it comes to videos and also
events
every saturday at 4 pm central time you
can listen live
worldwide on riverwest radio
we have our wisdom for life show dan and
i talk about all sorts of interesting
topics
what we're recording for this month
we're going to begin by starting to
about talking about
thought experiments so those are all the
things going
on up here in the great city of
milwaukee
i hope to get outside a bit and actually
enjoy
the end of summer and the beginning of
fall
hope all of you can uh you know go to
some of these
online events if not you know i'll see
you
when you're commenting on videos or
sharing the podcasts or you can find me
in social media
so have a great month and that's it from
here
you